be sure to tune in for our Conan in
Italy special airing Wednesday April
11th at 10 o'clock p.m. yes Calvin you
should come to my country next I'm sorry
who are you
oh hello my name is Francisco googley
only and I am the president of the
totally real country of bullet Oogway
I brought the map okay now I'm sorry
sure that just like you drew on a map
with a sharpie that's what that looks
like
anyway if you really wanted to
experience the best of Italian culture
you should have come to believe away
what do you mean the best Italian
culture would be in Italy right and all
the best French fries are in France
you're saying belivet Way has better
Italian food than Italy is that really
what you're saying yes believe Agua has
the best Italian food in the whole world
just come to beloved wise capital
believer Gua polis
most cities had a little italy but the
Bulova crapola has a medium italy medium
italy yes that's right we took it up
exactly one notch and while you're in
medium italy dine at one of our amazing
italian restaurants such as Guy Fieri's
House of exclamation points and tgin j
AO g WT s CI i o w WM aw eh
fridays i have no idea what that stands
for
it's thanks for thank God it's not just
an Olive Garden with different signage
on crap it is where we might as well eat
here Fridays cannot possibly be good oh
but it is possibly good they have all
the best Italian restaurant dishes such
as spaghetti and meatballs linguini and
meatballs meatballs and meatballs and
giamatti and meatballs right I stopped
saying balls that way well that is how
you say bowels in beloved weeks
wait the liver guize yes almost every
word the beloved Cui's is the same as
English with very few trampolines
you mean exceptions no thanks Conan
unmarried oh for God's sake
did you see I'm not visiting beloved
okay but at least let me name three
brands of Italian sports cars you can
find the beloved way the third one is
pretty unexpected fine go ahead okay
here we go
Ferrari Lamborghini Giamatti
I think we're done here I do have one
question why all the medals why are you
wearing all those medals oh these are
that's simple in bulimic why you receive
a medal for every Power movement oh
dammit what's what's wrong
Wow that's disgusting
that's absolutely disgusting
[Applause]
you